MATTERS.
ANYONE THAT DOESN'T WALK IN LOCK
STEP WITH THE RADICAL BASIS HAS
NO FUTURE.
THE FORMER DEMOCRATIC
CONGRESSWOMAN.
YOU HAD CONVERSATIONED WITH
SENATOR SINEMA.
WHAT IS SHE SAYING?
>> I HAVE KNOWN HER FOR MANY
YEARS.
-- SHE IS NOT ONE TO SWAY TO
POLITICAL PRESSURE.
SHE DOES HER RESEARCH AND WILL
DO WHAT SHE BELIEVES IS RIGHT.
TULSI GABBARD -- THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING HAPPENING ACROSS
THE COUNTRY IS THAT WE HAVE REAL
LEADERS READING OUR COUNTRY AND
THAT MEANS THOSE PUTTING THE
INTEREST OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
AHEAD OF ANY POLITICAL INTEREST.
PUTTING THE INTEREST OF THE
COUNTRY AHEAD OF THEIR OWN
PARTISAN POWER OR AMBITION.
THAT WHAT BOTHERS ME ABOUT THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
INSTEAD OF PUTTING THE INTEREST
OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE FIRST,
THEY ARE PUSHING THEIR OWN
SELFIS
SELFISH INTEREST AND THE
INTEREST OF THE ELITE AND
TREATING US AS THOUGH WE ARE THE
ENEMY.
IF YOU DISAGREE WITH THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY YOU ARE CALLED
A RACIST OR A RUSSIAN ASSET.
IF YOU ARE A CONCERNED PARENT
WHO WANTS TO BE INVOLVED IN YOUR
CHILD'S EDUCATION YOU ARE
TARGETED BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE AS A DOMESTIC
TERRORISTS.
YOU CAN GO ON AND ON.
IT SHOWS HOW DESTRUCTIVE THIS
LEADERSHIP IS.
>> Sean: ASSESS THE BIDEN
PRESIDENCY.
I CAN'T BELIEVE WE ABANDONED
AMERICANS IN AFGHANISTAN.
THAT SHOCKS MY SOUL AND
CONSCIENCE.
I CAN'T BELIEVE THAT JOE BIDEN
IS ALLOWING THE DISASTER AT THE
BORDER TO HAPPEN.
I CAN'T BELIEVE HE REMOVED
AMERICA FROM ENERGY
INDEPENDENCE.
WE HAVE MORE PEOPLE DEAD FROM
COVID IN 2021 THAN IN 2021S
2020.
HE WAS HANDED 3 VACCINES AND
MONOCLONAL ANTIBODIES.
I CAN'T BELIEVE NORTH KOREA'S
AGGRESSION AND PUTIN'S
AGGRESSION.
IS ANYTHING WORKING?
>> YOU ARE POINTING TO THE
CHALLENGES THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
FACE.
AFGHANISTAN THAT HITS CLOSE TO
HOME.
WE HAVE TO REMEMBER THERE ARE
STILL AMERICANS WHO ARE STILL
STUCK IN AFGHANISTAN NOW EVEN
THOUGH THEY MAY NOT IN THE
HEADLINES EVERY DAY.
THIS IS WHERE THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE DESERVE THAT KIND OF REAL
LEADERSHIP WHERE THEY CAN TRUST
THOSE WITH POWER IN THE
GOVERNMENT WILL LOOK OUT FOR US.
IT'S NOT SURPRISING THAT THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE WONDER HOW CAN I
TRUST MY GOVERNMENT WHEN MY
GOVERNMENT SEES ME AS THE ENEMY?
WITHOUT THIS FAITH AND TRUST WE
HAVE LEADERS WHO ARE WORKING TO
SOLVE OUR PROBLEMS.
THE EVERY DAY SERIOUS PROBLEMS
THAT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE
FACING ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
WHAT ARE WE LEFT WITH?
>> Sean: A QUESTION, I DON'T
REMEMBER WHEN YOU WERE RUNNING
IN THE PRIMARY, I DON'T REMEMBER
YOU STANDING OUT THIS MUCH FROM
THE CROWD.
DID I JUST MISS ITER --
>> YES.
>> Sean: THAT'S A FAIR ANSWER.
>> I CALLED IT STRAIGHT WITH THE
DEMOCRATIC OR REPUBLICAN PARTY.
THERE ARE THINGS I AGREE BASED
ON SUBSTANCE AND NOT PARTISAN
POLITICS.
I WILL SAY SO AND TAKE ACTION
BASED ON WHAT IS IN THE BEST
INTEREST OF THE COUNTRY.
>> Sean: IT'S OBVIOUSLY
A PASSION YOU HAVE.
DO YOU HAVE A PLANNED FUTURE?
ANY THOUGHTS OF RUNNING IN THE
FUTURE?
>> THERE ARE MANY WAYS TO SERVE.
MY SOLE FOCUS IN OR OUT OF
OFFICE, MY COMMITMENT IS TO
SERVE THE AMERICAN PEOPLE AND
DEFEND OUR CONSTITUTION AND OUR
FREEDOMS.
>> Sean: WELL, WE SHARE A COMMON
PURPOSE.
THAT'S WHAT I BELIEVE IN LIBERTY
AN